صاروخ ستور مشاهده البريطاني اكثر سلاحا
متقدما تتلقاه اوكرانيا منذ بدء العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه هو صاروخ كروز بعيد
المدى طورته المملكه المتحده وفرنسا بشكل
مشترك يزيد مداه عن 250 كيلومترا وهي
مسافه اقل بقليل من مدى انظمه الصواريخ
ارض ارض التكتيكيه الامريكيه السنه التي
يبلغ مداها 297 كيلومترا والتي كان
زيلنسكي قد طالب بها سابقا
يمكن اطلاق صاروخ ستورم شادو من الارض او
باستخدام الطائرات بل ويمكن تركيبه على
طائرات سوفياتيه الصنع التي تستخدمها
القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه قبل الوصول
لهدفه وعبر تقنيه حديثه تعمل باشقه تحت
الحمراء ينخفض ستورم شادو تحت الارتفاعات
المعروفه لتجنب اكتشافه من قبل الرادارات
يستطيع الصاروخ الوصول الى جميع الاقاليم
الاوكرانيه التي احتلتها روسيا بما في ذلك
شبه جزيره القرم التي ضمتها روسيا عام
وزير الدفاع البريطاني وخلال تقديم هذه
الصواريخ الاوكرانيا اكد انها ستبدل وقائع
المعركه خصوصا انها تعطي اوكرانيا القدره
على ضرب مواقع ابعد ب171 كيلومترا مما
توفره لها انظمه صواريخ هاي مارس
الامريكيه التي تمتلكها بالفعل
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات